[Música]
el nuevo Coloso de Emma láseres
no como el gigante impertinente de fama
griega con extremidades conquistadoras
extendiéndose de tierra a tierra
aquí en nuestras puertas al atardecer
bañadas por el mar estará de pie una
poderosa mujer con una antorcha cuya
llama es la luz de los prisioneros
y su nombre es madre de los exiliados
su mano como faro brilla en Bienvenida
al mundo entero
sus ojos dóciles comandan la Bahía
Ventosa enmarcada por ciudades gemelas
tierras de antaño quédense con sus
historias pomposas exclama ella con
labios silenciosos
Denme a sus cansados sus pobres sus
masas amontonadas gimiendo por respirar
libres los despreciados de sus
congestionadas costas envíenme a estos
los desposeídos basura de La tempestad
levanto mi lámpara al lado de la puerta
Dorada para obtener un análisis del
poema mire este video del siguiente
poema de esta serie
[Música]